Autsch!!
Oh nein, was für ein Schmerz!!
Was ist passiert?
Ich muss mir einen Zahn abgebrochen haben!
Übertreibe nicht so!
Aber wenn es so weh-tut,solltest
du den Zahnarzt anrufen.
Ja, ich rufe ihn sofort an!
Guten Tag, Zahnarztpraxis
Steiner, hier Frau Müller.
Guten Tag Frau Müller.
Ich brauchedringend einen Termin beim Zahnarzt.
Ja klar. Ich habe einen freienTermin
heute Abend um 17:30 Uhr.
Oder morgen um 11:00 Uhr
und am Nachmittag um 15:00.
Ich komme um 17:30 Uhr, danke.
Ihr Name, bitte.
Mein Name ist Luca Fischer.
Gut Herr Fischer, der Termin istgebucht.
Wir sehen uns heute Abend.
Perfekt, vielen Dank.
Willst du in der Zwischenzeitetwas
gegen die Schmerzen?
Hallo, guten Abend.
Ich habe einen Termin.
Mein Name ist Luca Fischer.
Hallo Herr Fischer.
Bitte nehmen Sie noch kurz Platz.
Die Zahnärztin holte Sie gleich.
Herr Fischer kommen Sie bitte mit.
Bitte, setzen Sie sich.
Sagen Sie mir: Was ist das Problem?
Ich habe einen Zahn, der wehtut.
Ich fühle die Hitze und die Kälte und
mein Zahnfleisch ist geschwollen.
Ok, wann war Ihr letzter Zahnarztbesuch?
Vielleicht vor zwei Jahren.
Ok, zuerst machen wir ein Röntgenbild
und dann schauen wir mal nach.
Bitte, legen sich jetzt hin.
Öffnen Sie den Mund weit.
Es ist dieser Backenzahn, richtig?
Autsch!
Ja..
Es ist nicht sehr ernst.
Sie haben eine kleine Karies,
die Sie entfernen müssen.
Zum Glück, ist die Karies ist nicht sehr tief.
Soll ich sie jetzt entfernen
odermöchten Sie wiederkommen?
Nein, wenn es möglich ist,möchte
ich sie jetzt entfernen lassen.
Natürlich.
Ich werde den Bohrer verwenden,um
die Karies zu entfernen.
Und dann werde ich die Füllung machen.
Ich mache Ihnen eine kleine Anästhesie,damit
Sie keine Schmerzen fühlen.
Öffnen Sie gut den Mund, jetzt gebe
ichIhnen eine kleine Spritze.
So, schon vorbei. Haben
Sie Schmerzen gespürt?
Nein, nein, gar nicht.
Super, jetzt spülen Sie gut mit Wasser.
Gut, warten wir eine Minute,bis
die Anästhesie wirkt.
Jetzt benutze ich den Aspirator.
Wenn Sie einen Schmerz fühlen, heben Sie
bitte die Hand, und ich höre sofort auf.
Alles klar?
Los geht's!
Sehr gut, Sie waren gut.
Zum Verschließen der
Kavitätverwende ich die Harzpaste.
Jetzt härte ich diePaste
mit dem blauen Licht aus.
Spülen Sie bitte noch einmal mit Wasser.
Wunderbar, Herr Fischer, wir haben es geschafft.
Wie fühlen Sie sich? Alles gut?
Ja... es geht.
Ok, also Sie haben eine leichte
Zahnfleischentzündung wegen des Zahnsteins.
Wann haben Sie das letzte Mal
eine Zahnreinigung gemacht?
Vor mindestens drei oder vier Jahren.
Das ist nicht gut, ich rate Ihnen,
das so schnell wie möglich zu tun.
Wenn Sie möchten,
kann ich Ihnen einen Termin geben.
Wenn Sie alle Plaque und den Zahnstein
entfernt haben, wird das Zahnfleisch besser.
Gut. Wir sind fertig für heute.
Bitte denken Sie daran: Kein Essen und
keine warmen Getränke bis zum Abend.
Wenn Sie keine anderen Probleme haben, können
wir uns nächstes Jahr zur Kontrolle sehen.
Danke für alles, Frau Doktor.
Ich danke Ihnen.
Und denken Sie daran, Ihre
Zähne dreimal täglich zu
putzen und die Zahnseidejeden Abend zu benutzen.
Ja, gut. Auf Wiedersehen.
Hallo. Ich möchte einen neuen Termin ausmachen.
Am besten passt mir immer
der Donnerstagnachmittag.
Hätten Sie da etwas frei?
Nächste Woche sind wir nicht
da. Wir sind im Urlaub.
Wir können uns die folgende Woche wieder treffen.
Donnerstag um 16 Uhr, ok?
Ja gut.
Perfekt Herr Fischer,wir sehen
uns in zwei Wochen. Schönen Abend.
Danke ebenfalls.
Ich habe Zahnschmerzen … beim Kauen/ beim Trinken
Ich brauche … einen Zahnarzt/ eine
Zahnärztin
beim Zahnarzt anrufen
Welcher Zahn tut weh?
Die Zahnextraktion/einen Zahn ziehen
die Zahnspange
der Zahnersatz
das Zahnfleischbluten
der Zahnbelag
der Stiftzahn
sich einen Zahn abbrechen
das Loch / die Karies
der Zahnschmelz
die Zahnseide
Ich hoffe, das Video war für dichnützlich
und du hast neue Wörter gelernt.
Wenn dir das Video dir gefallen
hat, gib uns einen Daumen hoch.
Und denk daran, dasseine gute
Mundhygiene sehr wichtig ist.
Bis zum nächsten Video!